in what's so great about Christianity
dinesh d'souza weighs in on religion
next he and Christopher Hitchens author
of God is not great debate the merits of
religion and atheism marma no Lasky
author of compassionate conservatism
moderates this is an hour 30 minutes all
of us are here because our debaters need
very little in the way of introduction
Christopher Hitchens is a columnist for
Vanity Fair and the author of many books
including God is not great how religion
poisons everything in a review of that
book Richard Dawkins praised the deadly
accuracy of Hitchens critique and
offered this advice if you are invited
to debate with Christopher Hitchens
decline lat
that
now to mr. Souza who has not declined
has written influential books such as
the end of racism and the virtue of
prosperity one reviewer said this about
Dinesh's new book quote infinitely more
sophisticated than the rants produced by
Richard Dawkins and Christopher Hitchens
what's so great about Christianity
leaves those atheist books in the dust
we shall see ground rules for tonight
dinesh goes first for ten minutes then
christopher has ten minutes each has a
five-minute rebuttal then we let them go
at each other directly for 15 minutes
we'll then entertain questions from the
audience not speeches or homilies
questions please with kings college
students getting the first three
questions Dinesh Christopher please pay
attention to the timekeeper who has
signs indicating a two-minute warning
and then a stop sign so let's begin
Dinesh you're up first
King Henry b8 used with one of his wives
he said I won't keep you very long
I this is this is Christopher Hitchens
in my third time around we've debated
other topics before it's our first time
debating this issue I really welcome the
opportunity in my opening statement I'm
going to make a positive statement about
Christianity in my rebuttal I will
correct the mistakes of Christopher
Hitchens now we're living in a very
unusual time in which atheism has
emerged as a kind of militant phenomenon
and in the face of that that's a little
bit odd because if you are an unbeliever
why be militant I don't believe in
unicorns but I haven't written written
any books on the subject I don't spend a
lot of time denouncing unicorns I live
my life as if unicorns did not exist but
what we have from the atheist side is a
is a belligerent attack on theism and
specifically on Christianity I want to
try to answer this attack by using the
same tools of reason and skepticism and
science and evidence that is the banner
under which the atheists march in no way
this evening will I rely on Scripture or
any kind of theology to make my point so
I'm going to focus entirely on reason
and evidence let me begin if I may this
way in reading through the various
atheist books by Hitchens Dawkins Harris
and the others if I were to make a list
of the values that the atheist cherish
the most I would list values like the
idea of individual dissent the notion of
personal dignity the idea of equality
the equal dignity of men and women a
antipathy to oppression inequality and
slavery the idea of compassion
as a social virtue now what's
interesting is that if you take a good
look at this list you realize that these
values came into the world because of
Christianity how do we know that partly
by looking outside of Western
civilization where we see that these
things that we take for granted there's
a tsunami that devastates a part a place
in Africa all the Western which is to
say Christian nations rushed to help
nobody else seems to something unique is
going on that's internal to our
civilization now you might say well
Western civilization isn't just built on
Christianity it's built on Athens by
which we can say classical reason and
also on Jerusalem which is Judaism and
Christianity and yet if you look at the
world of Athens which is to say Greece
and then pre-christian Rome you discover
that those were civilizations that were
based on slavery they were civilizations
where women were treated very badly they
were civilizations where human life
didn't count for a whole lot the
spartans
notoriously would leave the feeble child
on the hillside to see if it was still
alive in the morning and the great
philosophers of greece and rome viewed
these incidents with equanimity they
didn't think it was a big deal it is
only from christianity that these things
that had been uncontroversial for a long
time become controversial for the first
time in san Harris's book he tries to
blame slavery on christianity but the
reality is that if you look at history
slavery was a universal institution
practiced in every known culture the
Greeks and Romans had it the Chinese had
it there was slavery in ancient India
American Indians had slavery long before
Columbus got here
so it is Christianity that mobilized the
first movement in the world to oppose
slavery first the Quakers and then the
evangelical Christians took
a theological idea that we are all equal
in the eyes of God an idea that by the
way for some centuries was seen as a
merely spiritual truth and they gave it
a political application if we are all
created equal in the eyes of God no man
has the right to rule another man
without his consent this idea became the
moral engine of the anti-slavery
movement both in Europe and in America
and this concept is not only the moral
root of anti slavery it is also the
basis of democracy what's the premise of
representative democracy no man has the
right to rule another without consent
and I want to turn for a moment to
science because one of the rallying
cries of modern atheism is the supposed
incompatibility between Christianity and
science an incompatibility rendered
puzzling at the outset because if you
make a list of the leading scientists of
the West in the past 500 years you find
that the vast majority of them were not
only theists but specifically and
devoutly Christian this was true of
Galileo Copernicus Kepler Bry Priestley
Lavoisier you can just go down the list
all the way through Gassendi Merson
Mendel some of these guys were monks
like Mendel Gassendi and Marcin were
priests so right away you have a puzzle
we have literary theorist Christopher
Hitchens and biology major sam harris
positing a supposed conflict that was
not evident to the great scientists of
the west stretching from Kepler to
Newton I want to make perhaps a further
point about this so not only would he
scientist Christiaan not only did they
see their work as revealing the divine
handiwork in the universe but I want to
argue that modern science itself is
based on three Christian assumptions
that are at root metaphysical assumption
number one
the universe as a whole is rational the
universe embodies rationality now if you
think about it
that's odd it's pretty easy to say that
my friend bill is rational or
Christopher Hitchens is partially
rational it's another thing to say that
matter and objects and planets embody a
certain kind of rash now they follow
rational principles number two the
universe obeys laws that are
comprehensible in the language of
mathematics again if you think about it
that's very strange if I'm driving my
car I can follow laws I see a stop sign
I come to a halt
how does matter obey laws how does the
electron know what to do if we look at
matter it is unbelievably well behaved
it follows the laws of Newton's inverse
square law it obeys Einsteins laws the
point I'm trying to get at here is that
this is a metaphysical proposition a
third one the laws out there in nature
are mirrored by the goings-on within our
minds we can apprehend and understand
the laws very odd why should the
goings-on within our head match the
goings-on in the universe now if you're
a believer you know why God is believed
to be omniscient which is to say super
rational he built the universe to embody
rationality God is a lawgiver and the
universe reflects his laws we are made
in God's image we have a spark of the
divine so it's not surprising to the
theists that you have this arrangement
but for the atheist you can't take any
of that for granted this is faith based
science a final point we hear a great
deal about how Christianity has been
terrible for the world the truth of it
is if you look at the casualties of
Christianity the Inquisition the
Crusades the Salem witch trials I read a
book on the Salem witch trials
I had been educated to believe the Salem
witch trials had killed thousands or
very least hundreds of people i
discovered it at the Salem witch trials
the number of people executed was in
fact 18 the Inquisition if you read
Henry caimans book the most
authoritative study of the Inquisition
the Spanish Inquisition over 300 years
killed 2,000 people now just try to
compare that to the crimes inflicted by
atheist regimes not 500 not a thousand
years ago but within our lifetime if you
look only at the big three Stalin's
Russia Mao's China the Nazi regime in
Germany you have within the space of
five decades over a hundred million
casualties
so ithi ism not religion is responsible
for the mass murders of history I want
to end by saying that I think
Christianity has done a lot for the
world the world would be a lot worse if
we didn't have it I think even
Christopher Hitchens by the end of today
should be chanting if only under his
breath thank God for Christianity
well now mr. Chung
ladies and gentlemen comrades friends
brothers sisters I would be self
sacrificially a Christian if I cut into
my own time limited as it is to pay any
compliments so I won't except to say
that Ganesh is the most formidable
debaters I've ever encountered on any
subject that he has the further great
advantage of actually believing in this
stuff you wouldn't you try it you go up
and down the country ask a Calvinists
because you really believe in Calvin's
theory predestination ask a Roman
Catholic do they really believe in the
virgin birth you get all kinds of Life
of Brian evasions problem it's it's
metaphorical really no Dinesh believes
this that's very useful and then I want
to thank the alarmingly polite and
wholesome faculty and staff of the King
stomach
now I'm asked to prove that Christianity
is the problem and I'll try to do that
but for now all you need to think I
think I need to say is it's a problem or
part of the problem being as it is what
we know it to be a loose plagiarism from
Judaism and along with Judaism one of
the other two religions plagiarized in
turn that's given us all the blessings
of Islam so it's part of man-made
religiosity that goes under the trades
under the brand name of monotheism and
the problem that all three have in
common is that of faith faith in other
words that a man-made religion can
actually keep a promise of salvation not
just in this life and the next the
initial notice was was careful to say
well certain social ameliorations can be
written down to Christianity he didn't
claim that it was a salvation in this
life for the next just that it some of
its adherents of occasionally taken
liberal stances well I think he'll find
he has a higher standard of proof in
front of an audience like this that's
the first belief that faith involves and
second the belief that faith is in
itself a virtue transcending reason and
dispensing conveniently enough with the
need for evidence now it's my
proposition straight out and
straightforwardly that what we think of
as our morality as our ethics comes from
human solidarity and predates all forms
of monotheism don't let it be said in
your hearing ladies and gentlemen any of
you who have any self-respect
that died we know the story to be
fiction of the Exodus and the wandering
and the encounter in Sinai we know that
really should be a metaphor but taking
it to be true that my mother's ancestors
wandered all that time under the belief
that perjury and murder and theft were
okay only to eventually bump into my
Mount Sinai and receive the news wasn't
kosher after all we have to have more
respect for ourselves than that any
human society that had believed those
things wouldn't have got that far I
think it's pretty safe to say
Christianity in other words is
masochistic as well as parties say this
thing it attacks us in our deepest
integrity it says that you and I
wouldn't know a right action wouldn't be
able to derive it or a right thought a
right thought without the permission of
a celestial dictatorship that guards us
while we sleep that can convict us of
thought crime that supervises our every
waking moment that is in fact the origin
of totalitarianism in the in the
obeisances that it demands of us and
that will continue to judge us and
persecute us and sympathize us even
after we were dead this is my view as
well as being utterly untrue utterly
falsified by fearful human beings is
something that it is very fortunate we
possess no evidence for how horrible it
would be if we were condemned to live in
this posture of gratitude permanent
gratitude to an unalterable dictatorship
into his inspiration we had had no say
and let me add the worst of that would
be if that dictatorship was benign that
would be the thing that would make it
insufferable some of us refuse it and we
do so on what we confidently say are
moral grounds as well as the ground that
the story is a fairy tale made up by
fallible and opportunistic human beings
why else would I say in the time I've
got left that Christianity is as well as
untrue immoral well it offers something
horrible vicarious Redemption you're
told that by applauding a human
sacrifice a particularly cruel and
revolting one that took place before you
were born to fulfill a prophecy in which
you had no say condemns you either to
punishment and sin if you don't accept
it or if you do accept it offers you the
chance that your own sins can be
forgiven you well everything is wrong
with this picture first as with the
original proposition of a deer of a
deity it requires of you compulsory love
as well as compulsory fear you have to
simultaneously love someone you'll
command it
love them and be frightened over them at
the same time this is no way to teach
morals second you're told not that you
might get a second chance but all that
yours your debts can be paid
I can pay of debts if I care enough for
you I could serve your time in prison if
I wished but I can't forgive you the sin
I can't absolve you of the
responsibility of what you've already
done I can't wash you white as snow and
the desire to be washed in that way and
to be free of responsibility is itself
an immoral one it should be rejected by
anyone with any I'll repeat the term
with any self-respect so the vicarious
Redemption by human sacrifice is an
immoral preachment with very immoral
implications as is compulsory love
coupled with compulsory fear the idea
that the laws of nature can be suspended
in your favor if you make the right
propitiation z' is a lie Dinesh points
out what a lie it is Einstein says how
marvelous it is the great thing about
the universe is its laws never are
suspended
they are never suspended they do operate
according to a beauty a logic and a
symmetry that we don't quite yet
understand we're getting to understand
them better
dinesh words did not rather
intelligently to you what is
Christianity say ah those laws can be
suspended and in your favor too if you
make the right prayers and propitiation
z' and sacrifices there can be a virgin
can conceive a dead body can walk again
your leprosy can be cured the blind can
see nonsense it's not moral to lie to
children it's not moral to lie to
ignorant uneducated people to tell them
that if they will only believe nonsense
they can be saved it's immoral
the church a latarian concept of the
afterlife the idea the hideous idea
doesn't even occur in the New Testament
excuse me
doesn't occur in the even in the violent
rape and genocide filled books of the
Jewish Bible there is no punishment of
the Dead when God has destroyed your
tribe and had your virgins and your
children murdered in front of you and
your flocks and herds scattered and so
on and you also fall down to a bronze
sword he's done with you the earth can
close over you that's it you tangled
with the wrong tribe the one he favored
not until gentle Jesus meek and mild are
you told if you don't make the right
propitiation
you can depart into everlasting fire the
world the most wicked ideas ever
preached and one that's ruined the lives
and the peace of mind of many many
children preached to them by vicious
child hating old men and women in the
name of this ghastly cult which were met
here to discuss tonight in I don't need
two minutes to finish with this religion
but thanks I have a moral challenge on
this point answer me this if you think
the morality comes from the supernatural
and we require celestial dictatorship
permission for it
name me a moral action committed by a
believer or moral statement right
ethical statement uttered by one that
could not be made or uttered by a
non-believer I've asked this in a number
of venues and forums now I'm going to
keep on asking it I have not yet had an
answer if I was to ask anyone in this
room however could they name a wicked
action performed or a vile statement
made by someone attributable only to
their religious faith there isn't a
single person here who'd have to
hesitate for a second in discovering
what that was and saying it why is it
incompatible with knowledge and Sciences
for this reason we calculate that the
human species Homo sapiens has been
around now Carl Sagan thought perhaps
two hundred thousand years I would say a
hundred thousand not more not less in
order to believe the Christian message
are to believe this for those hundred
thousand years people were born died
usually many of them in childbirth
either the mother or the child life
expectancy of perhaps 20 years 25 died
of microorganisms they didn't know
exists it Genesis doesn't mention them
because the people who write Genesis
don't know there are microorganisms
earthquakes would have been terrifying
tsunamis volcanoes mysterious events war
and famine superimposed on this you can
all fill out this picture for yourselves
I'm sure that was our life for tens of
thousands of years on and on it went may
be a gradual upward curve of a sort we
seem to have made some progress very
painfully and with infinite suffering
and labor and with our solidarity still
intact now here's what you have to
believe you have to believe that Heaven
watched that for 98 thousand years and
after 98 thousand years decided two
thousand it may be trying to intervene
and the best way of doing that would be
to have a filthy human sacrifice in a
very remote part of Palestine and the
news of this has still not penetrated to
the rest of the world and I don't think
we'll be believed when it does and isn't
believed by me and can't be believed by
thinking person thank you
somewhat like the mosquito and the
nudist colony I am trying to decide
where to begin the
before
I want to begin with I want to begin if
I may with stripping away a kind of a
pose because usually when you debate the
atheist the poses I am a man of evidence
seeking the data I'm following the
evidence where it leads now what's
interesting is that if you listen to
Christopher Hitchens he offered no shred
of evidence for anything he said at all
he presumed he presumed
he presumed that God does not exist he
presumed the Christians made it all up
he presumed let's take one of his
seemingly former presumptions scientific
laws are inviolable I said earlier this
was an article of faith and it is there
is no scientific law at all for which we
could say that there are no exceptions
to it let's take one of the most
fundamental principles of science light
travels in a vacuum at the speed of
186,000 miles a second how do we know
that we've measured it one time two
times ten times a million times the
philosopher David Hume says even if you
measure it 50 million times you cannot
draw an unrestricted general conclusion
from any amount of empirical tests and
why how do we know that on a distant
star five million light years away light
travels at that speed do we know we do
not know we guess we assume science is
based on those kinds of assumptions so
it is the skeptic David Hume who
destroyed this idea that scientific laws
admit of no exceptions and if scientific
laws do admit of the possibility of
exceptions miracles are possible now
let's look at Christopher's portrait of
Christianity which is the heart of his
case it's not fundamentally about I
think evidence it's fundamentally
somewhere I believe Christopher called
himself and not an atheist and anti
theist I think what he meant by this is
it's not that i don't believe i hate god
I hate Christianity and I hate its
founder Jesus Christ why why now if you
look at history not even as a believer
here is Christ one of the mildest men to
set face on the earth harmed absolutely
nobody introduced radical new principles
which if followed would make our world
immeasurably better don't just return an
eye for an eye
forgive your enemies turn the other
cheek as a counsel of personal decency
and holiness the power of forgiveness
these are the radical new ideas
introduced by Christ they are seen
by Christopher as wicked ideas even
though they have done so much to make
our world what it is
it's sadomasochistic he says well if you
look at it purely from human terms
here's a guy he was killed brutally but
if you accept the Christian premise that
God said his son not just to be killed
but to be resurrected it's the
resurrection that's the core of
Christianity not the crucifixion so it's
not a sadomasochistic thing it is a
triumphant thing and here I want to get
to the core of all this I want to read a
quotation if I may from Christopher and
it's something he sort of said this
evening he says it would be horrible if
it were true that we were designed and
then created and then continually
supervised throughout all our lives
waking and sleeping it would be like
living in celestial North Korea here I
think we get an insight not only into
the motive and insight not only into the
motive of atheism but also into the
nature of God himself and here's what I
mean the way the atheist portrayed God
is meanly flinging the atheist into hell
wrong we hear from Christopher Hitchens
he doesn't want God he's shutting
himself out from God he doesn't want
heaven he sees it as a form of a
basement a form of humiliation a kind of
unending parade with flowers in which
he's going to be handing out Garland's
he doesn't want it in short the gates of
Hell are locked from the inside when the
Bible says that the salvation is a gift
of God many people think it means that
God gives you the gift of salvation no
that's not what it says it doesn't say
salvation is the gift from God it says
salvation is the gift of God God is the
gift and there's no compulsion we are
free to accept him or to reject him if
we reject him it is by our own choice
and God reluctantly gives us our wish
there's no sadomasochism in that there
is only free choice the choice to reject
God thank you
well a slightly low blow to kick-off
Regina I must say you didn't use your
time to prove God's existence either I
think and I think you needed more time
than I would if that's what we were here
to debate let's imagine that it was held
in common with between us and this
audience that it isn't possible to
decide these matters finally that no one
has ever produced an ontological proof
of God that is completely satisfying nor
a dis proof that is completely satisfied
however the burden surely is a little
more heavy on those who say I know that
there is a God and not only am i Adeus
I'm a theist I know what he wants in
fact I know who his son is in fact I'm
on sort of personal terms with the guy
in ways that are not evident to you that
reminds a slightly higher standard of
proof and to say you didn't come up to
that scratch my dear I'm sorry is to say
the least of it okay now why be militant
I was asked why do you care after all if
all this is nonsense why do I exercise
myself about it I'll give you one
example straight off there is a religion
that some of you would have heard of it
has 12 Imams twelve holy men who all
serve God a one God and only God one of
these Imams has gone missing
but is expected back imminently when he
will bring a rate of universal peace and
justice I don't know if any of you paid
attention to what I said earlier about
the Islamic plagiarism of Christianity
but sheer Islam is essentially a parody
of the Catholic faith now the people who
believe in this
you said unicorn I would say tooth fairy
or sinister Santa Claus proposed to
acquire thermonuclear weapons by illegal
means of presence and to deploy them
against not just Jews and Christians but
atheists secularists homosexual lists
rapists adulterers I think they've only
got me three times so far in this and to
bring about that happy thing that all
religions secretly want and
the eschatological end of days all
religions have this common deformity
they want this to be over they think
what we're going through is just a
prelude our life is a poor and
contemptible thing
bring on the moment when we'll find the
ultimate truth and be able to relax in
the saviours arms or in some promise of
heaven as the sort we were offered this
evening I say that I think it's a
contemptible offer and would be
contemptible if there was any basis for
believing that it was real
I'm not going to duck in case you think
I am the question of atheists and
secular atrocities but I'm going to
leave it to our next segment because
it'll take me just a fraction more time
and I'd like to do it in such a way as
to pin Dinesh somewhat more to the to
them Matt on it
those who it is argued there on this
moral point those who repudiate God will
have no basis for making their own moral
decisions or uttering learn ethical
conclusions that without this there
without this anchoring and overarching
belief in projection we would simply be
in the world of nihilistic chaos
choosing hear this and hear that option
for ourselves with with no one no
Anchorage of decency no ballast of
ethics well just consider if you will
because you all of you would have heard
that argument many times as well as this
evening consider if you will what the
corollary of it is if you look at it the
other way is there anything that is
forbidden to anybody who says they have
God on their side who says that they
have God with them is there any evil
that differ bit themselves to do is
there any enslavement or rape or
dispossession they haven't committed is
it not the case that I'll just take the
other case of the Shia Muslims whose
claim to a God and to his being the
spokesman of morality is just as valid
as that of any other religion as far as
I can see
well they in their originates forbidden
to execute a virgin whatever crimes she
may have committed in Iran can't be
executed as a virgin
but if sent us to the death penalty
instead aversion she can be raped by the
by the Islamic Revolutionary Guards and
then executed because she isn't a virgin
anymore
a piece of sadistic ingenuity that would
not have disgraced Chowk Amada or the
practitioners of the Inquisition and
does show does it not that not just in
the name of religion but rather I would
say more honestly precisely because of
faith and the certainty that it gives of
a divine endorsement that things are
done and done all the time and threats
made there no decent secularists no no
convinced atheists humanists could
countenance for a second and of course
atheism is no guarantee an atheist can
be a nihilist can be a sadist can be a
fascist can be a communist these are
these are sufficient rather than
necessary conditions that I'm talking
about but I hope they will at least to
some extent in your mind so ladies and
gentlemen have broken the connection
between religion and ethics as demagogic
Lee asserted thank you
yes will now move to 15 minutes of
cross-examination with Dinesh getting
the first question and the debaters
going back and forth now if you have a
question that you'd like to ask the
debaters you may in about ten minutes or
so
begin lining up over there and the for
the first three questions go to king
students and then we will let the fun
begin in general Dinesh your question
for Christopher could you name any
scientific law whatsoever for which you
have certain knowledge that there are no
exceptions no I couldn't I mean thank
you I take I take on I made a different
assertion I said that Einstein says the
laws of nature are not suspended that's
quite different and you chose to attack
a position I hadn't actually espoused
and you had said yourself that there is
an obedience to law observable I can
quote you but my point was that was an
article of faith but that was not a
demonstrated proposition Einstein knew
that and that's why Einstein was a
theist Einstein believed that God
represented a great mind that sustained
these laws in that way you'll completely
wrong twice Einstein was not a theist
Einstein was there Einstein was very
explicitly NOT a theist he was a deist
he said he was a he was a believer in
the god of Spinoza the God that does not
intervene in human affairs that does not
answer prayers but does not take sides
in human quarrels
that does not make judgments on human
behavior well there's no there's not as
powerful theism as it's possible to get
and you should have got this by now do
you know she really sure Christopher
you're a little bit there's a difference
between the deism and spinosum but well
I'll come back to that I want to I want
to turn to something else you asked for
how do we how can we reasonably think
that God exists let me ask you this
question scientists who begin to look at
the universe ask themselves this
question why does the universe have the
rules that it does why does the universe
operate according to the particular
dials
and parameters it has what if those
parameters were a little different and
the scientists who look at that said if
you change these parameters even an
infinitesimal amount if the
gravitational force was slightly
different or the strong nuclear force or
the electroweak force we would not have
this universe we would not have life we
would not be here having this debate now
what is your explanation for how we live
in such a fine-tuned universe it would
seem to suggest a fine tuner or designer
Darwinism is hopeless here because it's
not accounting for the universe only for
transitions among life so what is your
rational theory for why we live in a
fine-tuned universe right well there's a
good reason why no one comes to me for
arguments about physics but so I have to
take but I'm not ducking the question
just for your notebooks ladies and
gentlemen there is a book by Professor
Victor Stenger on the subject Dinesh
deals with it also in his book that
makes the bold claim that science
actually negates the case of existence
of God well Stegner says the laws of
physics come out of nothing you agree
with that further than further than I
would have gone I'm saying I simply I
recommend that you read it a chasm of
tautology eons at the feet of all those
who go in for this argument Richard
Dawkins actually said to me once he
thought it was the most interesting
argument he'd so far heard or
encountered in all the debates we've all
had with the faithful and it is because
there's something extraordinary about it
of course also appeals to us was
anything that says to us you know you
might not have been here but you are so
that must be something majestic is
obviously appealing to us sometimes
notice of anthropocentric look at the
consequences would look at look at an
example in our just in the suburb of
this argument where we happen to live a
tiny solar system on the very very edge
of the known universe with the Sun that
is going to flare up in a while into a
red dwarf go out having boiled us alive
on the only planet in its solar system
that can support or I think ever has
supported anything like life of the
other planets most of them are either
too or all of them I should say
much too hard much too cold this is just
in our hood on our block to support life
and that's true also of huge tracts of
our own dear planet which we happen to
know whatever argument we take about it
it's very sorry you're still avoiding me
a little bit boys on a clintus
cross-examine boys on a climatic
knife-edge so I would say bear that in
mind and I would add quite some design
and quite some designer well you said
that it was my turn to ask question yeah
well actually I will forego my my
question to you if you'll real ask your
question to me about atheist tyrannies
and massacres and I won't take too much
time on it I don't you ask it to myself
I'd be willing to ask you those
questions if you if you let me if you
let it go in a cross-examine otherwise I
ask a question and you take up all the
time well that's why I was asking this
one I was asking you if that condition
would seem fair I mean I must answer the
question which you have asked me in one
of your countries shall we leave it for
let me do it this way how about if I put
the ball in your court you pose the
questions to me on this topic and we can
go back and forth all right then okay
okay on this question then of atheists
and secular dictatorships that I've only
just mentioning has it ever struck you
that the original totalitarian movement
of the 20th century the one that
actually invented the term
totalitarianism popularized claimed it
for itself the movement of Mussolini
Franco Salazar the astara in Croatia
father T's Oh in Slovakia you'll see
where I'm going with this now is
basically only another term for the
Catholic right wing there's nothing
secular about fascism if there had been
the Vatican would not have signed
treaties and conquer debts with all of
the movements and governments that
fascism created I don't think I need to
waste very much more time on that
there's a big literature on it the
church keeps on apologizing for this as
for its engagements with similar
movements and governments in Latin
America after the Second World War after
the main battle against fascism was over
them the German version of this is not
the same it's quite clear the Hitler
disliked Christianity though he never
repudiated his Catholicism praised the
church in mine camp asked for his
birthday to be celebrated which it was
every year in every Catholic Church in
Germany by the order of the Vatican and
please wait my turn well wait biscuit in
view of this and view the fact that not
one person the courage of Paul Johnson
Catholic historian known to you I think
has praised your work up to fifty
percent of the vote and SS were
confessing Catholics none of whom were
ever threatened with excommunication for
their activities they did not see I know
of to be excommunicated by the Roman
Catholic Church was Joseph Goebbels and
you want to know why that was you want
to guess he married a Protestant Magda
Goebbels was a Protestant the church
said excuse me we do have our standards
all right
this is not secularism Ganesh and it's
quite false to say and it's actually
there's an insinuation that I reject and
resent it's not quite false to say that
these are the outcomes of secular
politics thank you when I first came to
America wouldn't you say supposed to be
a question
you notice that in a statement
christopher hitchens zoomed in on one
issue Hitler and the Nazis leaving
untouched indeed unmentioned the
scourges of communism he didn't not only
Jenner hold on hold on don't jump in
it's my time this is the Atheist
conception of fairness we hug the public
square completely to ourselves and drive
all the religions out look
you won't admit you wanted no I need
about two minutes to answer you son not
only did he not mention Stalin not only
did he not mention Mao
he didn't mention Pol Pot Ceausescu
Fidel Castro Kim jong-il now Richard
Dawkins and The God Delusion says well
there's a big difference the Christians
did what they did in the name of
religion but the atheists aren't
committing their crimes in the name of
atheism now this is what happens when
you let a biology major out of the lab
because here's a guy who has who knows
nothing of history I wouldn't accuse you
of that Christopher but all you have to
do is read Marx all you have to do is
familiarize yourself with communism it
was an explicitly atheist ideology that
sought to create a new man and a new
utopia liberated from the shackles of
traditional religion and traditional
morality it was no accident as the
Marxist said they always targeted the
churches they always killed the
clergymen and the priests and so on now
the case about Hitler is very
interesting you should read Richard
Evans multi-volume history of the Third
Reich in the beginning Hitler thought I
can make some friends among the
Lutheran's and the Catholics and so he
invented something called positive
Christianity which was basically Nazi
Christianity he praised Christ basically
because he said that Christ was the only
one alert to the dangers posed by the
Jews but you only have to read the book
to realize that Hitler hated
Christianity he hired people around him
who are all atheists their explicit goal
the moment they got into power was to
destroy the church which was seen as
doing what putting a little bit of a
moral bridle on the horrible plans of
Nazism so ultimately it's not the
Christians Christians ultimately are
accountable in some ultimate sense
atheists or not and that's why the
Atheist regimes killed more people in a
week than the Inquisition could kill in
three centuries and why because of the
maximum stated by Dostoevsky in The
Brothers Karamazov if God is not
everything is permitted
a gauging that I'm sorry a slightly
little blur you say you said look when
you're going to get through with your
questions so I lightly stop they've said
ha look at all the things you didn't
mention it it which I was just coming to
now I can I can play I can prove that to
anyone and I'm a little sorry to have to
point out to you because you have the
proof in your hands there's a whole
chapter of my book on this subject that
deals with Stalin and the rest of them
and you know that's true if the author
if the audience does well may I that's
not a question I'm going to duck to the
contrary it's why I've insisted on
taking up would that not be I appeal to
the fairness of the audience is that not
I've been doing for the last 15 minutes
so don't accuse me running for a
question I'm trying to confront now take
Russia in 1917 which I think you want me
to do is it not the case that for
centuries hundreds and hundreds of years
millions and millions of Russians have
been told that the head of the stage is
something more than human not quite
divine but a little more than human the
head of the church bazaar the little
father of his people
and that from him all blessings come and
under this benign Christian rule serfdom
the publication and circulation of the
protocols of the Elders of Zion the
original fabrication of anti-semitism
many other similar delight
are born where you'll Joseph Stalin you
inherit this situation you're not you
shouldn't be in the dictatorship
business I submit wouldn't you agree
if you can't take advantage of a huge
reservoir of credulity and civility like
that it's ready-made for you you can say
well let's have a heresy hunt and you
there will be heretics all right you
have a show trial an inquisition you can
say let's have miracles will claim we're
responsible of miracles and life
Sancho's biology produces 10 purports to
produce miraculous new harvests we will
say that all all blessings should be
attributed to my benign rule everyone
should thank me all the time and fear
the permanent workings of the evil one
against the happy state that we're
trying to create this is a city that
from very recognizable of the
relationship between Christian orthodoxy
whew
serfdom and anti-semitism now I will
take you're challenging us when you
point out to me a society that has
degenerated into famine disease paranoia
torture and mass murder because it has
followed the precepts of Lucretius and
Epicurus and Democritus and Spinoza and
Thomas Paine and Thomas Jefferson and
Albert Einstein if you can do that if
you can point to me a society that urge
and fell into horror by doing that then
we'll have a living level playing field
till then you know perfectly well we
don't have one and you're trying to make
it less fair still let me if I may have
the same time to answer right here we
see the way in which something there's a
kind of inequality of measurement going
on we find among the Atheist writers an
attempt to blame religion not only for
its own crimes but also the crimes of
atheism Sam Harris in his book the end
of faith says the following he's trying
to prove that suicide bombing is
entirely religious but he knows that the
inventors of suicide bombing in the
modern form of the Tamil Tigers who are
fighting over land and are fighting over
self-determination so he says this while
the motivations of the Tamil Tigers are
not explicitly religious they are Hindus
who undoubtedly believe many improbable
things about the nature of life and
death the cult of martyr worship that
they have nurtured for decades has many
of the features of religiosity that one
would expect in people who give their
lives for a car so the Tamil Tigers see
themselves as secular combatants in a
political struggle but Sam Harris
detects a religious motive because these
guys are Hindus and surely there's some
underlying religious craziness that
explains what they're doing now we turn
to Christopher Hitchens I want to read
if I may a line from Daniel Dennett in
his book breaking the spell he says this
he says it is true that religious
fanatics are rarely if ever guided by
the deepest and best tenets and those
religions so what al-qaeda and Hamas
terrorists
is still Islam's responsibility an
abortion clinic bombing is still
Christianity's responsibility here's
what he's saying if bad guys do bad
things in the name of an ideology the
ideology doesn't get to shake them off
and say those guys were just perversions
you have to take responsibility and the
point I'm making here is Christopher
Hitchens will not take responsibility as
an atheist for the crimes committed in
the name of atheism he is doing backward
somersaults to blame the Christians for
them so Christianity has a lot to answer
for we wouldn't need repentance if that
wasn't the case but Christians should
not have to answer for Mao and Stalin
and Hitler people explicitly dedicated
who if they could would destroy
Christianity and wipe it off the face of
the earth as would apparently
Christopher Hitchens
it's time to let questioners from the
audience getting on the run first three
questions kings college students do we
have a question
do we have some shy students here we go
and please address your question either
to to Nashua to Christopher but I will
not at all be shocked if the other
person then jumps in
mr. Hitchens you mentioned that having a
simultaneous love and fear of someone is
nobody teach morals now I don't know
about your upbringing but how do you
propose that we teach any self
respecting you say turell's morals
two-year-olds or should we wait until
they develop a good sense of self
respect for themselves to to learn world
on our own I've actually seen materials
undergoing some of these dilemmas in
fact some unbelievably vivid memory it's
not nice to think your children must be
evil or innately wicked but there is a
point what reason does enter it's just a
bit later than - you can't terrify them
into doing it you can some has bribed
them into doing it by saying Santa Claus
knows what they're doing it has an
almost magical effect but even as you do
a thing like that you feel slightly
cheap in other words this is going to be
a problem for us whether we are people
of faith or not but first of all isn't
it true that in childhood all learning
is based on piety and by that I mean
even if you were to teach somebody the
law of gravity as a child he would teach
it to them to be received on faith later
they would subject it to critical
scrutiny
I dare say I'm not going to disagree
with you that the observable laws of
gravity so why do you think are not
repudiated by any responsible parent
perhaps on I didn't know if either of
you have noticed this but you seem to
regard it's a revealing them disclosure
at the role of religion to treat us as
if we were infants I said one of the
things we are in that was my objection
to it
the first place
I didn't say if we were in prints I said
when we are infants look I think there's
a deeper point here the atheists have
kind of expected that as country has
become more modern more technological
religion would wither away they figured
out it's not going to happen and so
they've decided to focus on the schools
and so you find common themes in Dawkins
as book Harris's book Hitchens book why
do parents have the right to inculcate
religious values in the young
shouldn't that be something that is
taken over by the schools and done you
may say in an atheist way or at least
the schools are seen as deprogramming
the religious beliefs that parents
inculcate into children I think that
this is a little worrisome in a free
society the desire to detach children
from the moral training of their parents
to turn it over to experts like Dawkins
and Hitchens whom I think you can see
are not merely following the evidence
where it leads but have a certain
visceral dislike have themselves an
agenda no less fierce than that of any
Christian parent
this is a question for mr. de souza it's
a statement you made earlier that the
laws of nature reflect the goings-on in
our head I'd love to hear you elaborate
on that a little bit more the point I
was getting at is this when I said
earlier that the laws of nature the
universe is lawful we only have to go to
other cultures to see how odd that is
the muslim writer al-ghazali says how
can the universal veil how can matter
obey laws he says the universe is a
reflection in the mind of Allah
everything happens because Allah
intervenes every single nanosecond to
make it happen and that's not the belief
of Christianity now if you imagine that
in our heads are atoms and molecules and
neurons firing away I ask you what
logical necessity is there for the for
the workings of these neurons in here to
match the laws of the universe out there
Why should there be a correspondence
between the two again as a theist I have
an answer as an atheist he has a guest
and in fact he's been hanging an awful
lot on that guests tonight
the reason mirror I'm not defending this
or that miracle but I'm simply saying
that we have a very limited
understanding of defend any variables is
a better fact I'm sorry you haven't
defended any miracles as a matter of
fact well I'm in my book as you know I
defend one the resurrection I lay out
the evidence for it and in a very much
very much in an historical way but that
was my point that there's a strange
correspondence fear that ultimately
relies on faith and the only difference
ultimately with the Atheist his he
relies on the evidence while denying the
metaphysical ground on which it stands
isn't that true
metaphysical dramas a bit strong I think
it's whole cloth fabrication it's in
science matters I still think you mister
over there you if you see something
apparently involving suspension of laws
of nature shall we say the Sun standing
still so Joshua can win his battle all
right well the raising of Jairus
daughter or even my favorite miracle
returning of the water into wine at Cana
attribute attribute to the Hellenistic
influence that's still persisted in
Palestine at that time
you sought to ask yourself the question
which is more probable now the laws of
physics or nature have been suspended by
the way in my favor all that I'm under
misapprehension every one has to ask
themselves that question that's if they
saw it themselves if they take it as a
report issued through and filtered
through dozens of other known
eyewitnesses and corrupt texts John
Deere's then I would think anyone who
says something think of the
resurrections historic factories
advertising a willingness to believe in
absolutely in it let's have another
question this question is for mr.
Christopher Christopher Hitchens you've
said in past debates and I refer to the
debate between you and Doug Wilson that
morality has merely evolved and I say
merely because I think we'd all agree
Christian and atheists like the morality
is evolved anthropologically speaking
but I want to know if it's merely
evolved why can't i transcend the
current state of evolved morality what
standard what standard can you appeal to
well both morality is because we're
involved
and because of our evolution that the
lowly stamp of which as Darwin so
beautifully puts it we bear the fact
that we are primates and unarguable fat
our prefrontal lobes are slightly too
small our adrenal gland though there's
evidence that they're still evolving
which is I think heartening
you may have to be patient it won't come
in time for Tom Tancredo but his coming
and our adrenaline glands are too big
they produce more Drennan than we need
and there are other all kinds of other
problems we are our hope bearing and and
nature some people like to call this
original sin it's certainly true we have
some innate inbuilt design flaws there
isn't going to be any supernatural
solution to this and nor can it be
supernaturally commanded to go away as
full greville says you can't make you
can't create people sick and then order
them to be well that's what religion
does and because it it's because it
makes impossible demands on people and
insists they believe in possible things
and obey laws that count actually be
followed but I accuse it of
totalitarianism the essence of which is
the combination of authority with
Caprice
evolution although a powerful theory in
many respects doesn't account for three
things it doesn't account for the origin
of life which is presumed it doesn't
account for the origin of consciousness
for which Steven Pinker says there is no
explanation it doesn't account for
morality now the evolutionists have been
trying very hard to do it and they look
at morality as a form of extended
selfishness for Mom jumps into a car to
save a kid it's because they share the
same genes that accounts for about 1% of
morality but what about the morality
that has no genetic benefit I get up to
offer an old lady a seat in a bus I
don't do it because tomorrow I hope I'll
get her seat or she'll do the same for
me I give blood even Richard Dawkins
says there's no evolutionary explanation
for that give me liberty or give me
death the man who helped the good
samaritan when we do altruism or what
christianity calls agape charity with no
hope of return there is no evolutionary
explanation at all now I want to suggest
that this is pointing us to a much
deeper truth and that is this it is true
that we are animals in the sense that -
like animals and like nonliving things
obey the laws of nature but I want to
suggest that the very fact that we have
morality which depends on free will
means that there is a dimension of us
that it exists one may say transcending
the laws of nature here's why
a stone doesn't have a choice of whether
to roll down the hill it can't say stop
it merely follows the law on the other
hand in small decisions and big I have
choice here's a pen I have a free choice
to drop it or not if I drop it it will
follow exactly the laws of gravity but
my decision to drop it is purely a free
choice undetermined by the laws of
physics I can go either way and every
moral choice is of that nature our
entire vocabulary of thou shalt not and
don't do this and you shouldn't have
done that would have to be wiped out if
it was merely an extent you wouldn't
have to teach anyone right and wrong it
would be genetically programmed into
them so the idea
we are already moral by evolution
nonsense
morality ultimately does have to be
inculcated
mr. punch control well I think I'm sorry
with your with your leave that demands a
little correction first just take the
good Samaritan since he was already
known off by Jesus of Nazareth assuming
he ever existed
the man from Samaria he's his good
behavior can't be attributed to
Christian teaching by definition and if
you recall all the people who behaved
worst in that story were priests and
Levites and the other devout ones so
they seem to have go there I he seems to
have got his idea of human solidarity
without divine or religious permission
see an Eden is there anyone here who
isn't a serf can say for themselves yet
were you taught were you taught but it
might be a good thing to give blood was
this inculcated into you I can certainly
say it wasn't into me when I was the
socialist it was one of the things I was
most proud of I would go to give blood
because that we were proud of the fact
the British National Health Service
never had to buy any there was always
enough they were always enough people
don't go and give a pint because why not
how are you i banned it weren't giving
one i give a pint i don't lose it i
regenerate it quite quickly but someone
gets one something in that gesture
appeals to me chrismedonne somewhat a
good thing and it hasn't cost me a
sacrifice and i don't have to act as if
I've just done something incredibly
virtuous and self sacrificial umpires
and then yes as a matter of fact I do
have a very rare blood group and one day
I'm gonna need some blood myself and I
have enough other people are thinking
about me in their way to what
supernatural or celestial Commission is
required for this I ask you and I will
answer creates a mystery were not exist
I will answer in many cultures people
don't give blood in many cultures this
idea that you should give a part of
yourself for some guy that you don't
even know there's an old Indian proverb
the tears of strangers are only water
the point I'm trying to get at is it
seems to me that on a personal level
you're right
no one maybe had to say to you give
blood give blood your blood what you're
missing is the fact that here you are
atheist Christopher Hitchens educated
and raised in a Christian culture the
culture of Christian Europe where this
idea of compassion which was not there
in the world before Aristotle scorned it
Aristotle praised magnanimity the
superior man deigning to the inferior
man but not compassion in the sense of
feeling for the other guy it was Christ
who invented that and brought it into
the world now you are parasitic on that
you are acting out those virtues but
you're refusing to pay debt or even
acknowledge the Christian source of them
that it seems to me is a little
ungrateful historically
let's move let's move to the next
question and the person asked the
question can respond the other person
can then make a response to that and
then we'll try to go right to the next
question in order to have room for as
many as possible gentlemen thank you for
showing up tonight it was a pleasure
listening to you at this point I have a
lot of things I have to say but of
course I want to get succinct on it I
thought I had based on an idea the
materialization from pre existence into
existence then concluding with post
existence one might assert a lack of
definitive strength regarding post
existence as the absolute final end I
just want to touch on the notion of what
appears to be emerging from
non-existence and I understand that
there signs saying that things have
happened and I'm really not in either
one of your corners I feel but I feel
like this is substantial for me do you
have a question yeah the question is I'm
trying to generate some feedback because
I think maybe we could humble down and
say hey well you know we are somewhat in
the unknown based on linguistics and
we're somehow trapped in this sense of
the unknown I mean you may feel kind of
your science base I know you're somewhat
religious days but just merging out of
non-existence into existence and then
back into post existence do you see a
pattern there a 0 1 0 pattern and you
want to measure Christopher to answer
that and then Row 4 would indicate if
you filled out that pattern I would
suggest a 1 now just tell me what your
general idea that is your sense your
sense of that not necessarily taking it
to verbatim ie should take that as a
statement I move we take that as a
statement I don't know if it's
understood - no question okay let's move
on another
yeah dr. Hudson I come from Tonga no
pruners are Pacific prophecy before
Christianity came Tonga Fiji visually
have men for dinner and in Tonga the it
was mess my question is let's say the
inner gum in the Pacific what is your
what do you have to offer us as an
atheist what do you have Lauper's um
should I ventriloquist the question I'm
not sure everybody heard it
the gentleman is from the island of
Tonga which is in the Pacific used to be
British crown possession I don't if it's
to his I'm certain that's how the
Christians got there anyway thanks to
British imperialism and he says that
before the Christians came people were
freely dining off one another it's his
affair in Fiji yeah I've heard that I've
heard the stories it's often you know
it's often struck me as a tremendous
problem why was no Redemption ever sent
to this island why did it go on it
reminds me of the question I just I I
closed by in my original statement
ninety-eight thousand years of human
existence and heaven watches with
indifference we're expected to believe
2,000 years ago intervenes by means of a
human sacrifice in which also part and
which all must believe and that's the
salvation and it doesn't it doesn't this
is not offered to the Chinese who that
stage can read and can write and can
build boats and can have libraries and
gunpowder and spread an idea no no it
takes many thousands of years before
they're very weird for it gets to China
at all there are parts of Borneo where
people still practiced cannibalism where
this message still hasn't spread now
this isn't a problem for me because I
regard it as man-made as well it isn't a
problem for me this is my answer because
I regard it as man
made the pasta for you must be unless
you accuse humanism or secularism of
advocating cannibalism which it does not
them is how come this design this
revelation this Redemption this
faith-based and I should remind us
earlier that my identification of the
problem was precisely faith the
preference of data for reasoned evidence
why doesn't it seem to work why whenever
you ask why is there so much suffering
misery ignorance backwardness and
barbarism why is that question
unanswerable in the terms in which it's
asked you've just phrased it for Tonga
and Fiji
I think you're I think Christa was
missing the force of the argument here
which is not simply that the Christians
have been negligent in carrying this
universal message but that when
Christianity came to the rest of the
world it brought new values into those
cultures one time I said to my
grandfather how come we are part of a
tiny Christian minority in India and he
said two words
the Portuguese Inquisition meaning that
some very zealous missionaries possibly
accompanied with some bayonets came to
India and Christianize the Indians want
to say two things about this however
even though that may have occurred at
the beginning you found in a very short
time large numbers of Indians rushing to
Christianity and why as I look into this
matter as I got a little bit older I
discovered that in the Indian caste
system you have four castes with the
untouchables at the bottom and if you're
born an untouchable you're finished
there's nowhere to go you can't get out
of it many of the people in the
untouchable class were very attracted to
Christianity because they saw it as
affirming the idea of spiritual equality
among persons this was not immediately
or even over a long time translated into
complete political of social equality
but it meant something to say to
somebody you're not a nothing
you're not a dog you are a human being
and that alone counts for a lot what I'm
trying to say and I think what the
gentleman here was trying to say is that
most of the world didn't have that we
didn't have it in Western civilization
either Christianity brought it in now it
imported some of it from Judaism but
Judaism was for the tribe God instructs
his chosen people Christianity takes the
idea and Universal eise's it if you look
at the rights that are stated in the UN
Declaration of Human Rights you notice
something very interesting you read
those rights they're universal rights
no virtually all of those rights are the
specific legacy of Christianity it's
good that they're universal eyes because
Christianity wanted from the beginning
to universalize them but they are not
the shared rights recognized in all the
cultures and practices whether religious
or non-religious in other cultures so I
think we're seeing here from people who
have experienced it I don't care about
those inquisitors who came a long time
ago I'm kind of grateful to them
although probably my ancestors would not
have shared my enthusiasm but they
brought me into the orbit of
Christianity and Western civilization
and the fact that I have the values that
I do the beliefs that I do the respect
for dignity women equality and so on is
entirely the legacy of Christianity as
it came as it was exported I'm sorry to
say Christopher not by the British but
by the Portuguese the British could have
done a better job
next question please
the thing is just a tiny thing if you
can claim it if you claim it for one you
have to claim it for all it seems to me
it means that that means you accept that
yes Hamas does a lot of good with social
services
yes Luis cleric on gets black kids off
drugs yes the Mormons must have had a
point devout as there were when they
said black people didn't have souls
as they did until the 1970s that
everything were attributable to religion
must be a true must be attributable to
it you can't just pick and choose the
bits that you like the abolition of
cannibalism is one thing the Muslims say
they abolish to child sacrifice but
think of the things they also brought
and and tell me if this doesn't show
what I've been arguing from the first
that it is a man-made institution not a
divinely appointed one and that you get
exactly the sort of presidencies you
would expect them the world looks as it
would look if there was no God next
question please
my question is for a minute mr. Hitchens
sorry keep getting them but movement
evolution and change are hallmarks of
human history if religion poisons
everything as you claim why haven't we
just gotten rid of it and moved on well
I think that there are two reasons I'll
be quick um because I do in the ocean
the religion caters to our egocentricity
to our sense of self-importance as well
as to our masochistic tendencies I'll
say what I mean by that its religion
teaches us that we are originally sinful
that were sinners in the hands of an
angry god the Quran says we're made out
of a clot of blood the Bible says out of
dust that we were born evil wicked
wishes Brawl wish and grovel we should
be glad that Stalin even cares to a golf
dress but all be grateful I think this
is a disgusting attitude
you would I think fail to recognize that
it's a very accurate picture once
preached but worm as you are cheer up
the universe is designed with you and
night and God has a plan for you and you
learn so to this terrible groveling is
added a terrific arrogance as well thus
you get the phenomena to people like
Mother Teresa say rushing past you and
pushing off the pavement saying sorry
sorry
out of my way don't mind me I'm just on
errand for God and they call this
modesty that's why it appeals and the
second reason why it appeals is I don't
know why this is because I don't see
what there is to fear in it you're not
going to know when you're dead you're
not going to know it so there's nothing
to be frightened of but people are
frightened of death and the central lie
of all religion is that there's a cure
for this and an exceptional we made it
your own case an eternal life profit if
you make the right propitiation and the
right objections well I'm sorry I think
that since the height of immorality -
right people like that that's that's
what survives that's why it survives
let me answer if I may religion poisons
everything Christopher is known for
literary Flair I think what we've seen
here today when I first came to America
I lived in Arizona I went to a rodeo and
I'm sort of reminded of that we we have
a point here a point there and just a
lot of bull in between Oh
now here's what I mean by that isn't it
isn't it a case of gross rhetorical and
argumentative excess I mean did religion
poison Shakespeare or Milton or Dante on
Michelangelo or Raphael or Bach were
they corrupted by religion no their work
is in some ways a an exhibition of a
transcendent reflection as we see an art
even secular people should be able to
appreciate that and to recognize that
that is the special legacy of our
civilization built in part on Greece but
also an equal if not larger part on
Jerusalem now but we are now coming
closer to the core of what this debate
is about this idea here that religion is
a form of wish fulfillment Christopher
didn't think of that Sigmund Freud said
it mark said it in a different way
religion is the opium of the people we
can't face life we can't face death so
we make up stuff now I don't want to
give it I could give a religious
rebuttal to that which would look
something like this I can totally see
why in a wish-fulfillment world we would
invent heaven heaven is cool and if I
wanted to get away from my diabetes or
the fact of death I might say I'd like
to live in heaven I don't think I would
have made up hell hell is more severe
than diabetes it's it's a little tougher
than that so why would a will SH wish
fulfillment inventors of religion come
up with the rules of self-denial and so
on that make our life more difficult
more sacrificial we would make it easy
we'd start by taking out that
commandment against adultery if we were
get it all up now one final point the
idea of religionist wish-fulfillment
makes no evolutionary sense at all a
point made by the atheist Steven Pinker
he says this it is it makes no
evolutionary sense to make stuff up that
threatens your own survival
imagine this I am a rabbit I am being
pursued by a lion I have to decide
whether to run I decide I will not run
why there is another life waiting for me
even better than this one what would be
the fate of such a rabbit it would be
immediately eaten rabbits who engaged in
wish-fulfillment would have survived
that's the point you need a better
theory
it's nine o'clock and normally we would
move to concluding statements by our two
debaters but both of them before that
they told me they would waive those last
statements in order to allow another
question or two so let's have another
one
mr. Hitchens you began your opening
statement by decrying the very concept
of faith or beliefs in the absence of
good solid supportable evidence there
was an American psychologist named
William James who was a great believer
in faith and he insisted that the
wonderful contribution of Christianity
was to allow us to make leaps of faith
that the laws of science or even mere
common sense would you cry is completely
unsupportable um it's unlike a man of
faith can a completely rational mind
have the courage to for instance take a
leap of faith with a total stranger that
could leave to friendship or maybe even
with a dire enemy in the hope that that
might ultimately lead to peace I think
you're confusing the leap of faith with
a with a risk or chance the leap of
faith which I tribute to care guard not
to write his religious experience is is
that what's necessary to get you across
a gap where no evidence exists where
some of the evidence may be to the
contrary the provide the problem with
that though I can see the will behind it
is that you can't make it just once and
find yourself on the other side faith
got me across this chasm now I'm safe of
keep on making it if to keep on going to
church sometimes several times a week to
assure yourself you're right to believe
it in the first place and it becomes
morbid and ritualistic and irrational
and your back way started on the wrong
side of the chasm otherwise this
argument we will be having this argument
if Christianity had an answer to any of
this or any other religion either in in
Christopher's book he makes the argument
I think I've seen him quoted saying this
too that the absence of evidence is
evidence of absence you don't see
evidence for something don't believe it
I would suggest that in the empirical
domain in the world of human experience
that is a valid principle it even
applies to miracles if someone came to
me and said my leg grew three feet last
week I would say let's bring in the
doctor with the measuring stick let's
see if it actually happened we are in
the domain of verification however the
non sequitur here is the following there
are many questions that are vital to our
life because they would affect the way
we live that are not in the empirical
domain let's say I would ask you is
there life after death
Shakespeare says death is the
undiscovered country
no one who's gone there has ever come
back and it's certainly not in the
natural so here's the question how would
you subject that proposition to testing
what possible evidence are you looking
for when it is not in the empirical
domain Christopher's has automatically
rejected out of hand since there is no
evidence but there is no evidence in the
domain where evidence is unavailable so
I would suggest that here we have the
dogmatic atheism that because it doesn't
know
refuses to believe now if you ask me do
I know I would say no on this point I
don't know either the believer shares
the agnosticism with the atheist but the
difference is the believer says even
though I don't know
I believe remember the statement of
belief is not a statement of knowledge I
know my brother I wouldn't say I believe
in my brother I know the guy the reason
I say I believe is because I don't know
so what I'm saying is why is it in any
way more irrational for me to take a
position on one side of an issue than
for him to take the other side of the
issue on which there is no empirical
evidence on either side I would submit
it's a leap of faith for both of us the
only difference is I am leaping toward
God he's leaping against him
last question voice thank you both my
question is for Christopher I've heard
you say in several debates that I've
seen online that you do not deny the
existence of either the transcendent or
the numinous that's the language that
you use yes and I was just thinking
given your obvious antipathy towards
lidge's belief and superstition I think
a lot of people come to religion and
come to religious belief after having
some sort of peak experience and either
a transcendent experience and experience
of the numinous so I was my question is
how would you advise someone or what
what what sort of recommendation would
you make for someone that has that sort
of experience but doesn't want to
interpret that in let's say a religious
vein because I think many people will
turn to religion because they're so just
profoundly disoriented after having like
some sort of experience of transcendence
okay well what I say I've ever touched
the United State is that the
transcendent and the numinous which I
wouldn't trust anyone who didn't have
Baptist which should be distinguished
from the supernatural that for example
I'm just about to forget his last name
Francis as his first name he's the power
cords of the human genome project I have
with you I haven't gone discussion
Illinois says that he was hiking one day
I think it was in the Pacific Northwest
there was a frozen waterfall that had
three streams frozen frozen trilogy if
you like and at that moment she says he
got down on his knees and accepted Jesus
Christ now I will simply have to say of
someone whose work I drew Norma suspect
who I believe I've quoted correctly but
that to me is a wild non sequitur the
people who talk like that arm it may be
a deformity in me I think it's white
noise white noise and I don't think I'm
missing anything because I'm quite just
as fond of the music of Verdi say as I
was when I thought he was a Christian
presumably was as
I found out that he wasn't and many
other great famous musicians and
painters who actually turn out to in
their devotional efforts not to have
been themselves diversion and that's why
I don't think I'm gonna to take a bit of
my answer to reply to to Dinesh just now
on this point of whether it's whether
these things apply to both of us no they
don't when I say I think that's a
meaningless statement I'm not making a
meaningless statement myself anyone can
say that they understood what I said
about Francis Collins this remark by the
same token why had a debate on hugh
hewitt's program and very fair-minded
very intelligent question
he caught me on with his favorite
presbyterian he said this is the man you
have to beat I said all right we went
out in one of the questions I asked him
was about the resurrection do you agree
with the verses in Matthew that says
that the time of the crucifixion all the
graveyards of Jerusalem opened and the
jet came out and walked and greeted
their old friends and so forth I was
going on to ask him because if you do it
seems to me to cheapen the idea of
resurrection if it was so commonplace
that's where I was going with it but he
thought I was asking whether literally
true or not and he said well as a
Christian yes I absolutely do believe it
but I'm not so sure I believe it as a
historian I will just have to say that
to me that nonsensical remark is a
statement of faith and what I've just
said about it's nonsense it's
nonsensical character is not itself a
meaningless zermatt because it's
intelligible to everybody here and that
should weigh a little in this argument
it seems to me well
I don't know what Francis Collins was
getting at but I I can tell you a little
bit about what Keppler was getting at I
think when you look at nature you notice
that there is enormous intelligence
embodied in nature and this is I think
for the person who thinks about it a
deep mystery Kepler was measuring the
movements of the planets and the
theologians all told him that the planet
should move in circles and Kepler
realized that was not the case but he
said I bet you based on faith that there
is a divine plan for the motions of the
planets that is far more ingenious
mathematical symmetrical and beautiful
than anything you have thought up so far
and when he revealed Kepler's laws he
said I found it this is if you will
God's plan for the universe there's a
deeper point we're getting at here
earlier Christopher said what does
Christianity do that's different why
can't an atheist do the same he's
written a book denouncing Mother Teresa
somewhat irreverently called the
missionary position I do want to tell
you a I do want to tell you is a very
grief I want to tell you a very brief
story about this and then try to say why
someone like Mother Teresa might be an
object of such derision
mother Teresa was in Calcutta
apparently hugging a leper at which
point an Indian walking by casually said
to her I wouldn't do that for all the
money in the world she replied I
wouldn't either I'm doing it for the
love Christ
the point I'm trying to get out here is
look I can see him chomping at the bit
and I never before before I turn it over
to you I want to give an explanation for
why he's chomping at the bit
religion makes moral demands on us and
Christianity asks that we move outside
of ourselves and consider first the
welfare of the other person now this is
ultimately a little bit of an annoying
and irritating and a difficult doctrine
even Agustin prayed make me chaste or
Lord but not yet the Christian feels
this to the atheist I want to suggest is
chafing under the moral rules of
Christianity that's the concentration
camp he's talking about ultimately he
realizes that a life lived according to
the Ten Commandments is a life in which
we are accountable we all live in the
world where bad guys sometimes that make
off with the money
where good guys come to grief it's not
fair what goes around doesn't come
around but religion says that at the end
of the day what goes around does come
around there is a Last Judgment there is
an ultimate accountability I would
suggest that as human beings we chafe
under that we hate the idea that our
actions are ultimately accountable that
even the things that we do in private
and in the dark are under scrutiny and
are being recorded atheism is a massive
rebellion against that but it disguises
itself as moving along the strick
pathways of reason it's not an
intellectual revolt it's a moral revolt
could we have been we've been going at
this for over 90 minutes now and it's
time to sadly cut it off
three concluding notes first if you have
information cards for kings college or
love notes for Christopher or Dinesh
please give them to an usher as you're
leaving secondly Dinesh here will be
signing copies of his new book and third
thank all of you for coming and please
join me in thanking our two debaters
what's so great about Christianity
Dinesh D'Souza is also author of what's
so great about America for more of his
work visit Dinesh D'Souza calm